azione
come vedete non ci troviamo all'interno
[Musica]
sistemando un paio di cose all'interno
terme a cucina che non stavano
funzionando
ecco perché la fine ha deciso di
ospitarci all'interno della meravigliosa
feritoia oggi faremo una ricetta
particolarmente facile anzi estremamente
facile abbiamo trovato sul giallo
zafferano
una ricetta che teoricamente amano gli
inglesi ma ha un origine americana
perché faremo il pollo alla coca cola
che riuscirò in qualche modo a cui
possiamo partire
partiamo subito per fare il pollo alla
coca cola avremo bisogno 4 coscette di
pollo una città 3 cucchiai d'olio 4
cucchiai di zucchero di canna avoletto
del merda 2 cucchiai di salsa di soia e
mezzo litro di coca cola come gli trova
in questa cucina comodissimo anche
perché la linea essendo una cuoca
provetta proprio tutto quello che
servono all'interno di una cucina io
credo che questo qui non utilizzi meno
per cucinare perché sia un'arma di
difesa personale
un tagliere dove no figurati se la linea
un tagliere a un coltello per tagliare
per allontanare magari taglia
direttamente sul piano panorma si rovina
il piano no alcuni materiali non si
rovinano magari e quel materiale li
voglia fare una petizione i figli a
colla questi due verificata nei prossimi
episodi di cucina buttata io so che voi
li volete o una domanda dov'è il
tagliere cioè mi sono trasferita adesso
mi sarei trasferita molto prima ma
purtroppo sono fatta sequestrata ha
detto khatami sull'auto ma mio malgrado
sinceramente ma posso andare sul piano
poi daniele sul piano e questo materiale
anti taglio contenuti
taglio che non si levano il mio lavoro e
non promuoviamo velocemente la testa il
culo rimuoveremo pure l'anima ma la
cifra non ha l'anima al centro della
cipolla nella mani ma infatti lo vedi
che ti va sempre viaggio e vedi che un
po di anima c'era no sono strati perché
le cipolle anno gli strati la tolgo ma
fede ciao questo dio
in realtà la linea non abbiamo il culo a
delle pietanze pesche tipo quella con le
vongole e non ho mai assaggiato tra la
vita si dice chi la pensa giornate
abbiamo tagliato anche sto facendo bene
quali sono i trucchi conta 10 collanti
sapete fateci sapere quali sotto ma non
ci credo
no ma vabbè che lo ha fatto entrare
quasi ma che cazzo di solito non ci
posso fare se moltiplicata quanti quasi
avete di là perché abbiamo sette ma
tutta st cipolla car ancora che comunque
è una ricetta americana
siamo tornati ad avere il nostro audio
originale scusa scaricata un secondo la
batteria rendiamo un cucchiaio
aggiungiamo due cucchiai di soia la
nostra cipolla che per il frattempo si è
poi un po bruciata come piace a noi due
erano tre cucchiai di soia è noto creare
un idoneo perché per la soglia di usati
cucchiai e per olio no perché l'odio
secondo me kg conta spruzzino contenuto
è uno sfigato erano andati colpo io qui
sento l'asia velocemente andiamo ad
aggiungere simone che merda oddio mai
più o meno è così
fate sciogliere lo zucchero
il calore si sa mai hard maillard del
processo di majar del governo in realtà
però bene calore aumenta la sua abilità
delle cose presenti nell'acqua fredda
se dovete il sale e poi la riscaldi il
sale si scioglie di più perché il calore
aumenta la solubilità va bene capitolo
si intende un certo che conoscono la
chimica hanno capito no vabbè senti
l'odore prendiamo le nostre coscienze
124 rosolare fissiamo lasciamo rosolare
perché poi arriva la magia e poi del
pase fatto ragazza abbiamo finito qua
comandiamo per un ora ci vuole un po
tirati è non sono isolati e ancora cosa
serve rosolare per tenere i succhi della
carne io pensavo per evitare di dare
quella cosa di bollito invece se tu vai
rosolarla rimane un pochino più
rosolando to sigilli l'esterno e
trattieni succhi capito che cosa era il
fold io l'ho sentito anch'io
ok non c'è non possiamo risentire nella
registrazione
guarda non li sto rosolando a casa senza
poggia mestolo di una casa come fa
entrare un rivisto in questa cucina
la prima gara vi erano in testa che la
crisi nella quintana magia ci siamo
mezzo litro occhio che noi e dovrà
arrivare tipo fino a qua coperchio sopra
abbassiamo la fiamma meglio gentile un
timer un'ora resto quella è la coca cola
è un aspetto agghiacciante posso dirlo
un abitante nella frazione di mettere il
suo praticate
na na na na na na na na l'avete mai
visto nella leggenda di cristallo si sa
molto di nicchia
chi lo conosce me lo dica qua sotto
mette un like personaggio fantastico mi
ha fatto crescere
mamma mia comunque vada pure io no sai
che facciamo una live e ce lo vediamo
non guardate perciò guardiamo insieme
possa permettermi di suggerire anche un
piatto ci sto bene e sono veramente una
savana ragazzi diciamolo come la linea
saccheggia l'eredità io non lo trovo
allucinante ab e inquieta quel nero
caramellato carbonizzata quindi abbiamo
scoperto che non lo assaggia giusto
gianmarco ma non devi incamminarci
andiamo qui direi di sporzionare dal
ruolo e altamente popolosa fa un profumo
buonissima l'aspetto che devi un attimo
comprenderlo c'è un odore particolare
posso dire oh ragazzi se lo fate prima
aspettate il nostro parere poi se lo
fate
mandatemi su instagram perché secondo me
potrebbe essere una delle cose che uno
dice incredula nè no che cosa sta
dicendo mi hai appena conquistato con
gli hanno fatto assai di peggio in
questo forum acqua ricetta detox
l'inutile tabata c7 mendes e il 20 si è
fatto l'anno la stampa ci sono ma il
peggio è lavorare ogni giorno con due
che sarà riconoscente
basta per operai lavoro questo incrocio
dimetto devi dare una mano
invece di criticare con disegni di buono
ma dimmi che ha immortalato il momento
perché la succederà mai più quella
partita dominata ne pensa non è il mio
piatto preferito e allora ogni caso
assicura parte di un po bruciata il
cosciotto e un po banale no certo non
qualcosina per dargli quel gusto più
magico della netta nonostante una regata
ha l'odore non è convincente l'affetto
non è convincere lei st morello di gente
di pagare ragazzi è così c'è un picco di
caffaro la sorpresa poi c'è un declino e
poi torna nuovamente articolo cioè non
s'è mai più rialzato mi lascia un buon
sapore quando lo prendi in bocca a un
buon sapore durante un declino secondo
me questo è invece deve essere fatto con
burro perché sono per le cose però è una
polverara di farina per farlo tipo
scaloppina come la recente promossa
promosso assolutamente promossa la
prossima volta farò aggiustando un
pochino di cose un pochino meno sul
fuoco un pochino più a rosolare il pollo
all'inizio per raggiungere la parola
ragazzi se l'ho fatto trecatesi su
instagram di scrivere al canale attivate
dal cappello di [ __ ] metteteci un like
ci vediamo giovedì con un nuovo video
alle 14
[Musica]